avec nous diane lemieux président
directeur général de la commission de la
construction du québec bonjour madame
lemieux parce qu'on sait finir vingt
mille travailleurs de plus par année au
cours des dix prochaines années est ce
que ça s'appelle un manque grave de
waimes et cesser les données de
l'association de la construction du
québec je salue le fait qu'ils ont
qu'ils essaient de documenter bon est ce
que ces quinze mille 18 ou 20 c'est bon
on pourrait discuter mais c'est
clairement une tendance est clairement
une tendance moi j'ai initié aussi des
très beaux est la commission de la
construction du québec de soi au moins
une année et demi qu'on a des signes est
l'intrus la construction elle est sur la
même planète que la planète québec
canada est américaine alors et les
enjeux de recrutement de repérer des
nouveaux travailleurs de les maintenir
un emploi ils sont ils sont vécues ou
signalés sur les constructions
qu'est ce que vous avez manqué dans le
secteur de la construction est ce que ce
n'était pas prévisible dans un contexte
de vieillissement de la population
notamment dans un contexte très bon sur
le plan économique avec le taux de
chômage qui baisse sans cesse comment se
fait il qu'on ne l'avait pas vu c'est à
dire que le sol est construite la
construction est assez particulière
parce que les tricycliques moi j'ai
connu ces dernières années beaucoup de
soucis la part de travailleurs qui
manquait de travail
c'est des cycles et des fois c'est des
sites qui sont assez brusque
ceci étant dit demain situation nous
faut quand même faire quelque chose
c'est pas une c'est une industrie qui
est très l'écosystème est quand même
assez sophistiqué pour toutes sortes de
raisons officielles wind and it des
enjeux de de compétences de s'assurer de
la compétence de travailleurs de la
conférence et des chantiers dans
l'industrie est quand même une certaine
dose de réglementation qui sont
quelquefois du célèbre bouger mais
maintenant dans le contexte où les 5
parce que laisser mon les a évidemment
c'est pas dans toutes les régions c'est
pas pour le port tous les métiers mais
il reste quelque chose de qui commence à
se généraliser
est-ce que s'il y avait moins de
réglementation au moins de rigidité dans
le fonctionnement du secteur de la
construction est ce qu on serait dans
une pénurie ou une rareté de
main-d'oeuvre selon vous non je crois
qu'on aurait tout de même des problèmes
parce que par exemple on note qu il ya
une baisse depuis un certain nombre
d'années
inscriptions dans les formations des
pays qui mènent un diplôme donc dans
l'un ou l'autre des métiers de la
construction chez les jeunes où il ya
moins d'inscriptions donc moins de
jeunes qui s'inscrivent et moins de
jeunes qui complète les deux pays voilà
alors d'expliquer ça il ya un phénomène
qu'il ait beaucoup à la formation
professionnelle au québec ont un enjeu
dans beaucoup de disciplines où il ya
moins de jeunes qui s'inscrivent moins
d'attrait on a on peut faire des théo
des grandes révélations ne beaucoup
inciter nos jeunes à faire des diplômes
universitaires et cetera donc un enjeu
de valorisation des métiers et ça bien
évidemment les messines la construction
souffre également
est-ce que vous souffrez encore beaucoup
de tout ce qui a été révélé durant la
commission charbonneau sur le secteur de
construction il ya dix ans ils demandent
les enjeux de réputation par exemple de
l'industrie par exemple on s'est passé
il faut s'y attarder on sait que 30 %
des travailleurs et des travailleuses
qui se rentrent dans les métiers de la
construction vont quitter
au bout de 5 c'est énorme et ça il faut
en comprendre les phénomènes et on sait
également que 55% des femmes parce que
c'est nouveau on a beaucoup travaillé
pour une plus grande présence des femmes
dans les métiers 55 % des femmes
quittent après 55 ans presque presque
deux fois plus donc il ya des tensions
un problème vous avez l'intention qui
effectivement un des éléments qui
expliquent toute la question de
l'organisation du travail mais aussi du
climat de travail et pour pour quelque
chose à vous dire quoi ça mais ça veut
dire que il ya encore dix ont une
manière de s'exprimer de régler ces
problèmes qui - contemporaine j'essaie
de le dire gentiment mais l on dit qu'il
ya des gens qui sont exaspérés de ce
faire je suis un réseau canada je veux
pas être trop cru mes deux soeurs
écuries sur les chantiers disons le
clairement et ça finit par jouer c'est
un des facteurs qu'on est documente
alors comment on change ça il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire mais derrière
moi j'ai engagé au printemps dernier
avec les associations patronales et
syndicales de l'industrie une discussion
sur la pénurie
on a mis toutes les données sur la table
on essaie de bien se comprendre de
comprendre les phénomènes
a commencé à évoquer une certaine liste
de solutions
j'ai un conseil d'administration dans
les prochaines semaines je crois que
l'industrie aux hackers et les
représentants de l'industrie ont encore
que c'était c'était ce qui fonctionne
bien donc je veux privée je veux
discuter avec l'ensemble de l'industrie
un certain nombre de mesures un peu plus
rapide parce que quelquefois le rythme
est un peu las de faire bouger tout ça
mais là je crois qu'il faut s'y mettre
et un peu plus rapidement identifié je
sais pas combien ça soit un dixième de
mesures jeunes de maisons mais parmi les
mesures on parle d alterner les études
et les stages par exemple oui c'est
davantage les jeunes curieusement d'un
presque tous les secteurs d'enseignement
on a souvent ses programmes d'
alternance travail-études c'est pas
présent dans l'industrie de la
construction pour toutes sortes de
raisons or il ya beaucoup d'appétit pour
ça les centres de formation
professionnelle ont envie on veut
l'expérimenté ça et c'est une manière
évidemment c'est pas un sujet ce qui va
faire toute la différence et l'addition
de petits gestes qui vont finir par
faire la différence
donc c'est une manière l'alternance
travail-études d'abord de s'assurer que
les jeunes qui s'inscrivent aime ces
métiers là et déjà les employeurs
peuvent leur pays
repérez du personnel fort intéressants
qu'ils auront goût de suivre dans la
vigne est ce que la rareté actuelle
ralenti parce que là on est dans une
année record en termes d'heures à venir
mais est-ce que ça ralentit on à port
gentil on l'a on a posé la question à
l'occasion d'un sondage auprès des
employeurs et ils nous disent que d'en
terminer stratégie pour compenser le
manque de main d'oeuvre
ils doivent et alizée travaux étant les
échéanciers ses clacs alain effet ce
nouveau leur clairement vient de mieux
merci beaucoup savent à cette ligne
c'est bien pour cet entretien ce soir